but I'm trying to be better to be
someone worth something in this world
taking on the role of Bryce Walker was
definitely not an easy thing to do but
you made your character super believable
Justin Prentiss
and although Bryce was a despicable
character you gave him death and made us
believe that people can change Justin we
love how open and understanding you are
in real life and we're happy to know
that you take your position very
seriously but I think I can make it
better
Netflix is 13 reasons why is loaded with
complex themes that can often get the
cast and crew in trouble the cast does
everything they can to respect their
viewers and offer help when needed keep
watching to find out which rules the
cast of 13 reasons why are required to
follow and we will continue to fight to
make sure that no one is assaulted
harassed or abused at this school
therapy dogs the show subject matter is
so difficult it took a toll on the
actors the producers noticed this and
decided to bring in a group of sweet
therapy dogs to help lift the cast
spirits this brought comfort to the cast
as they navigated through those heavy
scenes Dylan Manette's who plays the
role of play Jensen said there was a
puppy per hour and that they really
helped the cast this was especially
important for Kathryn Langford the
actors who played Hanna on the show she
had some of the toughest teams of all
she said she felt supported and not just
by the puppies
she said executive producer Selena Gomez
genuinely cared for every actor on set
she added that Selena was very generous
as well which is evident in her choice
to bring on support animals access to
counselors the issues on 13 reasons why
shouldn't be taken lightly simply acting
them out can affect every actor and crew
member on set I don't care so in
addition to support dogs producers to
god support a step further after some
severe scrutiny on the show's reckless
decisions regarding sensitive scenes
they knew they had a responsibility to
get it right in future seasons they
learned a great deal from their mistakes
now they are all about creating a safe
space for both the actors and the
viewers producers have provided therapy
for the actors to help
recover from the heavy scenes in the
show nonprofit organizations also offer
insight on how to tell these difficult
stories in responsible and respectable
ways the newsletter 13 reasons why takes
on issues that have been previously
hidden in secrecy the show brings mental
health and many other important concerns
to light the conversation grew and
became more interactive as the show
continued in response producers created
a newsletter inviting people to share
their personal experiences give words of
encouragement or express how the show
made them feel one-in-six a certain
nonprofit organization called one-in-six
took an interest in the show they
offered up their expertise in working
with real survivors of assault over the
age of 18 the organization didn't come
into the picture until after the
controversial scene with Tyler in season
2 that scene led a surge in the
organization's website signifying that
there was a real need for one-in-six to
offer support to viewers the
organization agreed to come on board as
consultants for season 3 Deven druid who
plays the part of Tyler shared that the
advocates of the organization consulted
on every single script in season 3 one
in six were there every step of the way
whether they were addressing issues
answering questions or offering
around-the-clock support producer
parents the producers of the show took
on more of a parental role while on set
they offered constant support and
encouragement throughout the process
which was crucial for each of the actors
Devon druid stressed the importance of
preparation for these tough scenes and
topics mental health was a top priority
for the cast crew and viewers of the
show devon shared that he believes we
must take good care of ourselves and
those around us he urges viewers to
reach out and utilize the resources
available so no one has to struggle with
these issues alone devon is proud of the
show's creators for taking on a
nurturing role he believes that all of
Hollywood should follow their example
social media before 13 reasons why I
came out Kathryn Langford it didn't have
a public Instagram account Kathryn never
wanted to become a celebrity with a huge
social media following she shared that
she believed it was all about her work
as a performer not about Fame but Selena
Gomez gave her a gentle push encouraging
her to open up and be more available to
fans Selena told her that the show is
resonate
with young adults like Catherine social
media is a great place for her to talk
directly to those who feel they can
relate to her character Hanna that was a
major reason why she made her social
media accounts open to the public she
does this work to connect with people
and her Instagram account allows her to
do that on a personal level beyond the
reasons the actors also sign the
contract for the bonus material
connected to the show called 13 reasons
why beyond the reasons it's more than
your typical behind-the-scenes bonus
feature it offers an in-depth look at
the reasons they filmed the scenes the
way they did on beyond the reasons the
cast discusses consents bullying and
depression as a society we tend to shy
away from these hard topics they also
have clinical psychologists talk about
the shocking real-life statistics behind
Hanna's particular situation the
psychologists offer guidance tools and
education for teens who might be
suffering silently in similar ways due
to the show's heavy content the cast of
13 reasons why does everything they can
to make their viewers feel safe and
respected if you or someone you know
needs support please call the national
suicide prevention hotline at
[Music]